哇 今天台湾股市又強烈的反彈
今天反彈
今天昨天反彈了3356點
真的還是假的
第二個
不好意思
備贈元件跌聲反彈
還能買嗎
第三個
哇
一直咳嗽是有大事情發生
台幣狂貶剩下32.48元
一年新低外資都落跑
只剩內資在撐盤嗎
這是好事還是壞事
今天三大重點我一次要跟大家講個夠
因為這個股票實在太強了
台股今天又大漲千點
最後收漲在44825點
光是這兩天就反彈了3000多點
而上週五大跌了快3000點
真的彷彿就像一場大笑話
重點是投資長的世界先進
前天還打到跌停
而投資長當機立斷
直接帶會員進場加碼
結果今天直接跳空開高還鎖上漲停
另一檔投資長逢低貸會員買的
就是我愛美元中美金這檔股票
投資長昨天還帶新會員加碼買進
剛進場今天就直接開高噴漲停了
還有投資長的精彩
已經連兩天都急拉噴漲停
真的太強了
你手上還沒有標股嗎
這種行情你還找得到
像投資長這麼強的分析師嗎
接下來就交給我們經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%的記錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
投資長好
Lily 各位的朋友大家好
哇 投資朋友
今天台灣股市大漲特長
是
這個尾盤有點弱一點點
我只要問大家一件事情
你告訴我
有哪個分析師股票比我們強
精彩漲停
而且精彩要创新高了
应该说今天创新高了
今天突破利子新高了
我记得两档股票在今天7月22号
突破新高
创新高
你去看
今天2492
华兴科也拉展停了
可是你觉得
这拉展停你看起来
你会觉得他创新高吗
不会
很难
对
我们不敢说完全不会
但很难
也不是近期内
国际也是一样
从没有
你會覺得它短期內有辦法創新高嗎
Lily有辦法嗎
應該不會
很難 尤其國際大家喔
有現在喔
或有那個PTSD啊
很怕再一次災難啦
所以都不會
還有另外我再跟大家看一件事
來245全新
哇CPU這種股票
你覺得
你家會覺得短期內會創新高嗎
看起來不會對不對
所以展停板有很多種
全新的展停板
它不是新的展停板
是舊的
沒辦法讓你賺大錢的展停板
可是我們三三七四的精彩
同沒有
瞬間每個老師可能都有精彩
可是誰能像我一樣精彩
我要給他取個名字耶
叫什麼
好戲登場
同沒有
誰能像我一樣實實在在
我說普通會員就賺110%喔
你自己看
突然間每個老師都有展停班
沒有關係
我們不要去攻擊人家
我只要告訴你我跟別人差別
因為我們真的很實實在在
你看精彩
從200塊開始再講
240 280 290 276
2303 304 350 400
380 400
恭喜3374精彩
股價開高走高
連兩天都急拉噴展停
我買進到現在最高已經大賺115%
我持育看好他 耍持股活力虛報
有沒有
精彩我已經賺了115%
這還是普通會員的簡訊
我剛才底下就留言啊
說每個人都賺錢
新會員救會員其實都賺錢啊
是
真的
而且
應該說原則上啦
我認為99%啦
我不知道有沒有萬一的例外啦
有人會告訴我買到
比如說買到群聯
群聯我也有很多人也有賺錢
是
可是基本上我應該
我基本上我認為九成九的會員都很滿意
唯一不滿意的是有些人錢賺得太慢了
他們想賺幾千萬
然後一個月內沒賺到
有些人運氣好了可能前幾個月就賺到了
基本上我會不會太抱怨的啦
不會來抱怨的
精彩大賺115%來喔
瞬間可能每個老師都有展停板
誰能向我賺那麼多
這是事實
好
除了精彩以外來又有股票展停板
5483中美金
這一度展停板不是嗎
沒錯吧
中美金你去看一件事
中美金線圖也是很漂亮
我會員這一個禮拜大跌的過程中
來看清楚
這跌3000多點的過程中怎麼樣
投資廟
我只買兩檔股票加碼
第一個是來看清楚
剛才金產算115%嘛對不對
對
來
裝美金
有沒有看到
我們多次買進最高
已經獲利38%了
昨天甘加碼
這是普通會員秀的簡訊
我們昨天甘加碼
是
今天暫停版
昨天甘加碼
我這兩個這個禮拜
跌的過程中我只買兩檔股票
今天這兩檔股票都暫停
你告訴我現在全台灣誰績效比我好
我願文其詳
我再講一件事 我有投資30年的經驗
當然分析是20年的經驗
我帶會員來最績效最誇張最狂的就今年
最猛的是現在
現在行情很難做
基本上我會員每一個都滿意啊
中美金 沒錯吧
昨天剛買進喔 有沒有到
昨天還大跌喔
這就算了 來 畫面給你 畫面給我
中美金我是說取名字
我不是人家突然有一堆股票喔
我都會取名字
我不是每天取名字喔
中美金不就是我愛美元嗎
我愛美金嗎
沒錯
剛才那個精彩不就是
好戲登場
好戲登場嘛
因為show time
精彩的show嘛
世界先進
我們要是要跟他還要還要還要
還可以取個名字
環球金
環球小姐世界小姐都可以
而且昨天還跌停殺下去了
是不是
是
殺下去是不是跟環球金一樣
沒錯
跟730元環球金一樣
然後最後漲到1430元
1490元以上
世界先進152元
禮拜一跌停
你想買多少個買多少站都隨便你
今天
可一天後今天暫停
我請問你世界先進跌停的時候
我有沒有講
有
實在的分析師啊
大跌的時候很多分析師都不理你啦
被動元件突然變變變變不見了啊
股票都變不見了大跌都變不見了
我照講啊
我請問你我這裡報所有會員
我是不是只買這兩檔股票
世界先進
我大跌的時候
今天有買一檔股票
沒買到 因為要穿新高
印象中應該沒買到
維新啊 今天穿新高
還有維新啊 今天也穿新高
我是不是只買兩檔股票
是
大跌過程中只買世界先進
只買中美金
今天都展平板
世界先進今天開盤就展定盤
我請問會員嘛
我的股票真的很實在啊
2377你看還有微星
今天給你創新高啊
你看到這種股票現行
你們自己看一下
我剛才不想不要說CPU一堆啦
那個PCB也有啦
還有那個CPU啦
你跟我講Proway這個1300跌到730
這種股票能短期內創新高嗎
不行啊 看起來都是死毛條
我不說他不好
可是的確他的基本面沒那麼猛啊
看起來很難
有沒有 我也不知道攻擊別人
不知道攻擊有CPU的人
或攻擊有CPU的分析師
我講的是
我的股票的確比他們強一點點
有沒有 為什麼我們今天股票那麼強
就在扎實的做選擇
做研究
2481強貌 有沒有
我之前一堆人
我說這種小型的股票
有人在推薦了
我們就不參與了
我不這樣講嗎
我說這不是構成的塞牙縫
你告訴我啦
你看這個強帽子很誇張
你看天天暫停
天天殺下去
這一波你只要聽信別人的話
你去買的整流二級體
你基本上通通套牢
當它發動的時候
人家在網路上給你推薦的時候
他直接給你攻暫停
你買都買不到
在這邊已經有人在吃貨了
你把人家抬轎
我講多我覺得
你好像我要攻擊誰
可是我要告訴你
我們分析師不一樣
我是全台灣唯一喔
而且是唯一一個分析師喔
因為之前有人就硬要搞我
沒有關係
還搜尿那些會員或非會員
搞個製救會
結果呢
哇 證交所幫我們證明
你知道什麼證交所怎麼查嗎
他查你那個股票
我推薦你的股票
在任何 在那個時間點
不是只有我的戶頭
是所有市場的戶頭有沒有偷賣
我買有沒有偷賣
證交所法院全台灣唯一證明的
絕對不跟阻力掛鉤的分析師
而且
我不只是不起訴
我是千傑
千傑是至少兩個警察官
認為郭哲隆分析師
沒有問題
別人給我亂提高
確固啊
千傑是至少兩個警察官
你知道嗎
因為千傑是直接讓你都
讓那些要提高的
你都不能散訴了
沒有必要
為什麼
因為我選的股票就是油價的量
聽那些人講的話
你心心可能賣到70元
現在700元
800元
對不對
唉
聽那些人說
這次好像很壞
唉
沒有 你去想想看
你要找到分析師
我們來看一下
來
這次我是會員
我可以祝我生日會員嗎
可以
你要取個名字
你不能叫做你在生命力量
那你的名字是什麼
生命力量嗎
請問哲哲大人
最近怎麼沒有名義可以猜
我就故意不要讓你猜
很多股票賺得很開心
是不是
哲哲這幾天直播都靠
記憶體
記憶體記憶體
三球都漲停
沒有沒有沒有
我南耳科出掉
今天還有人問我
哲哲你南耳科出掉了
今天漲翻了
來來
南耳科有辦法直接創新高嗎
我不能說不行
他的現行不差
可是你去看
你們就是這種
賺了100%
很多人
不是很多人
有些人
是屬於賺100%都不開心的人
你懂嗎
還不開心
不然他怎麼會說
南亞科有沒有賣飛
眼前人覺得南亞科
折折賣飛
那個應該不是會員
因為會員實在賺太多了
是
南亞科我賺61%
你們知道
我之前南亞科
還有賺過204%去年到今年12月的時候我南亞科家來家去如果用力滚力来说的话应该差不多300%有了或接近300%真的啊你用力滚力来算的话
所以拿雅科到底谁是专家
我是专家
我跟你讲
我要讲的是说
你在心里面想着
哇
今天拿雅科暂停了
我是不是卖飞了
郭忠祥是卖飞了
或者我要去买它
那代表你心不满足
心不滿足沒有關係
可是心態不滿足不行
你知道為什麼很多人
會國具會在1200套牢嗎
華新科在645元套牢
你知道為什麼嗎
因為他們心不滿足
他們本來獲利一倍了
結果看到他們天天還在漲停板
你看我國具
賣在多少
六七百元
他還給你漲到1200
這邊還給你
從700元給你漲到1200
你受不了
你就在那邊買進
就跟牛頓一樣
買那個南海公司的股票
一開始買大貨全勝
然後後來賣掉之後
覺得是泡沫
受不了自己追在最高點
國際會賠錢的人
都是一堆人
包括一些主動型ETF的經紀人
覺得太強了
我不得不買
我要跟他買
我一定要趕上這一波的主流
因為我賣飛了
為什麼我沒有買到
我很貪心
可是你忘記股價的基本面
你忘記它漲很多了
你忘記它從300塊漲到1200了
所以南亞科你有這種想法
賣飛了你很危險
我賺了60幾%
加起來說300%了
還不夠嗎
你應該不是我會員
因為我會員每個都很滿意我的績小
我換來的是其他的精彩100%
連發科100多%
哪邊錯
你如果有那種很危險的想法
你會買在1200的國具
然後最後腰斬
你會買到一千塊國具就要漲
所以我跟你講節奏很重要
今天我的節奏基本上是百發百中
你不要每天你想到我要賺最多
那照你這樣講
我國具應該也被批評
我的研發課被批評
為什麼五千塊不賣
我賣四千多塊
沒有這回事
你永遠買最低賣最高
天天展停板
那是老頭顧
老AI可以買老頭顧的分析師
你不要去追啊
你們都很奇怪
你們都先看老師有沒有賺錢
基本上看了所有的分析師的節目
沒有一個會跟你講天天賠錢
所以你不需要看那些東西
你應該是看到那些
不過實在有沒有老師
我有沒有實在
我這麼多粉絲
我能不實在嗎
第二個我不屑不實在
只是選鼓真的很厲害
佩服
真的不能貪心
你有沒有看到
是不是
一堆老師國際很難
我們要去批評哪一些分析師
我只會講一個情況
今天直播的人3000多人
也沒關係
因為我們的粉絲有些部分粉絲
部分人
就是疊了之後才想到國澤龍
我OK
只要你不要亂批評我就好
哲哲微星
微星還會噴嗎
微星看起來就要噴了好不好
感謝哲哲的神節奏
繼續支持哲哲
這是很專業的細節
很細節的專業
是啊
請問老師偽創基本面
偽創基本面跟鴻海跟管達一樣
基本面也很好
今天是因為
偉串今天生產的
在美國的第一片
輝達的晶片
就是利多
跳空長停
它會長下去
我覺得這個利多還不足以
讓它改變大家對基本面的想法
雖然基本面本來就很好
OK嗎
這次我相信會十萬點
已經All in的華碩了
你這個邏輯
我最討厭的聽一半
誰叫你股票要All in
單一是股票的
知道嗎
是啊
你不要單一All in股票
你大概你真的二到五檔
差不多
你懂不懂
二到五檔
ETF买一两个就可以了
记得我这句话
二到五檔
为什么
因为基本上
台湾股市上十万点
我认为九成五以上
这是九成八以上的股票
通通都会创新高
甚至很多股票占一倍
可是不代表所有股票都会涨
听懂吗
懂
你看微星这一波死不涨
它是到现在才涨
你知道为什么微星会涨那么夸张吗
为什么
因為微信很好
微信很簡單
它去年的時候
還在200
210元
有
今晚間多少
去年216元
現在155元
因為它擺脫
它根本沒動
去年
台灣股市一串新高過程中
它根本沒動
所以我說有沒有可能
像是買微信的人很開心
如果是之前買微信的人
一點都不開心
所以我怎麼知道
你的華碩會不會拉上去
你都聽我的邏輯聽一半
很多人的邏輯都聽一半
我講對不對
邏輯聽一半
不代表你的股票會創新高
所以你要找專業的
只是你的股票
很高的機率會創新高
非常高
那不代表百分之百
股市沒有百分之百
它只有機率的問題
為什麼這一波我的會員
游刃有餘
甚至說游少好閒
這四個字都可以
不好意思了
不是聽你們
太閒了
每天在數鈔票
輕輕鬆鬆
輕輕鬆鬆 真的輕鬆鬆
對不對 何必衝衝滿滿呢
明明可以游刃有餘
2377的微星它一直噴出去
它一直噴出去
那我就說很多股票
這個股票我們這樣輕鬆的
去做這些股票
為什麼你節奏很重要
選低基級的股票不會害到你
我都不懂
波羅威你們之前都知道
哇 航海玩
兩三百元就要買了
你一千元你還跟著追
你家賺一倍 賺五倍 賺三倍 他不會走啊
你不會走啊
走啊
國際人家不會想走啊
會啊
你聯發科
一千事不推薦
兩千事不推薦 三千事不推薦 四千事不推薦
快要五千塊了
之後你才推薦說
聯發科一萬元
難道的啊
節奏很重要
哪個分音師可以講出來
我也是國際受害者
2018年是哲哲開始最紅的時候
我大概 其實我當分析師20年對不對
對
等於差不多2027年
我就考上分析師了
是不是
好老
2007年我有考分析師了
你看2007年的時候
我其實一開始
我都說某某分析師很幸福
這之後都熬了好幾年
因為幾前當分析師很苦
比如說你要去上那種
哇 財經電視台啦
上他們節目才會好
買他們節目才好
然後要巴著人家
我是很討厭我巴著人家
我自己很討厭
因為我自己
前身就有傲估
我就覺得我就比人家強
我就不喜歡去捧人家
因為我覺得我自己很厲害
可是你要上電台
你得要捧人家
是
講出以前的八卦
上那電視台你就會很猴
然後你買那節目有夠貴
然後貴還不是你買的到
然後你買個節目
應該買個100萬
很扯喔
好辛苦喔
100萬
有時候不知道成本被誰墊高了
我也不要講變批評人家了
不是 我不是講電視台
這樣我沒說過這句話
這句話沒說過
好啦
那
重點是以前真的很辛苦
然後以前又不像網路化
你知道嗎
哇 你一定要電視台
很辛苦
只是真的是隔很多時間
才慢慢紅的
你知道嗎
那時候我開始
真的很紅的時候
就是被鬥元件啦
因為我從200元一路拉
那時候我也是選股比賽
冠軍而且選股基督保持者
所以你說那個被動員券
我記得清清楚楚
怎麼賺錢之後怎麼被害到了
有些錢不一定要賺
懂不懂
我就是有些錢我不一定要賺
所以我不會偷偷去買股票
然後叫偷偷買股票
然後會員買的時候
我把它賣給他
這些錢我不賺
你懂不懂
國際被動員券好就好了
我根本一定要買
我連買記憶體
我跟你講你去問業界
到底記憶體比較缺
還是被動元件比較缺
還是記憶體
記憶體問題是長太多而已
可是記憶體還是比較缺
被動元件沒有那麼缺啦
我記得那時候不知道是問誰
問國劇的誰 高層
會不會漲價 希望是
不是 我就是會漲價
你懂不懂
這句話我記得是有這樣講的
我印象中
哪個分析師會跟你講說
以前股票賺大很多錢
最後我還變賠錢
然後一堆同業的 那時候我開始很紅啊
亂攻擊我說我國際買1200
你怎麼不說我國際買了200元
你沒有嗎
對啊
就是這些學類史
難者則一直成長
造就今天的我
造就這20年 這30年
績效最強 最屌
最強大 最暴力
最誇張的績效就是現在
就今年
懂嗎 好不好
這跟大家講
台子已經跌了
你怎麼比較拜託
台子已經跌多少
每天都要想這些東西
那我標題是比較誇張的
剛才納斯達克還要跌到0.7%
小納斯達克
所以現在跌100多點還好
重點是上跪指數能拉起來
好不好
這只要買國具受傷
又敢進場什麼原因
因為我就是很不想買啊
可是我看他就是要創新高啦
很簡單
我就是心裡面我不去管他
很多人說
很多人有個問題
這問題很好
為什麼你還買國具
是不是 一朝貝斯二
因為你看那線圖 你看這邊
我們看這一個地方
我教你們記住線圖
很好
有建設器的問題
我回答
算來算去的問題我會直接封鎖
好不好 我們這邊的話
你看這邊
是不是整理很久了
對
它就是要噴出去的
基本上這邊就要買了
它這邊噴出去
噴出第一根
第二根 第三根 第四根
你在350以下這邊還不趕快買
就會錯過危機了
在這邊
最晚在這邊300多元要買
300元以下就要買
因為我現在這邊買
我現在這邊買
這邊買
300元附近
這已經噴出第一個呢
這個你看
這已經整理過
它在第二次噴出
代表是來真的
對不起
這邊
它代表第二次噴出
代表是來真的
第二次噴出代表來真的
你懂嗎
所以基督現行告訴我
而且我也知道
AI它的確
會造成它的需求大增
聽懂嗎
可是我也知道
它很多的是規格品
而且沒有什麼技術含量
所以我建好救手
我還是要告訴你
我覺得國劇要再創新高
很難 很難 很難
你只要相信我
因為我認為國劇的高層
還是有可能
是有一些賣股的計畫
或者是資本遊戲
簡資真資這樣搞
你會失去信心
不要說我沒說
我大膽預告
今天是2026年7月22號
好不好
人的個性很難改
但我不是說我批評他
人家至少有人力啊
併購了在2000年左右
我記得沒錯的話
併購了菲利普的那個
被動元件的部門
逐漸的茁壯
好不好
這跟大家講
只能現在加入會議還來得及嗎
來得及啊我還把不得他拉回我就說啦我現在超出績效很難可是你看我這幾天只買一檔股票5483中美金展停板然後咧只買兩檔股票
還有
世界先進
展停板
我的股票
到今天還一堆股票創新高
這麼難做的行情
一堆股票是死貓跳
一堆股票你都分不清楚
是不是跌升反彈
還是真的產生的
可是我的股票清清楚楚
就是暫停創新高
清清楚楚就是穿一年多的新高
你告訴我兩檔股票
微星跟精彩
我知道你聽到很多分析
是現在有了
他的有跟我的有有差嗎
當然差很多
微星我取名字叫什麼名字
星星之火
是
足以燎原
微小的星星
你告訴我這些股票我都有全名字
我對它都有感情的
然後都創新高了
這些股票是我的
別人是來插花的
別人來插花的績效
跟我的績效差那麼多
你還不趕快選擇我
那我沒辦法
我沒有辦法
我沒有插
因為我不插
我不插一兩個
看不懂的賞戶或會員
因為很多人相信我
好不好
OK嗎
太大聲了吧
OK
請問資源
資源今天也有漲
中美星為什麼今天展停板還沒打開沒鎖匙
你可能問為什麼今天本來氣象報告說不會下雨的
最後有五貨雷陣雨
你來亂倒
有些東西很難去解釋
就像四萬三
我在說四萬三還是四萬點我怎麼知道
反正四萬點我就是買個幾千萬攤物
就這樣子而已啊
好不好
Detonade好帥
謝謝大家
不要
世界有沒有可能算新高
世界當然有可能算新高
人家為哲家都報名牌
電源管理IC的承受制者是缺我
不是每個承受制者缺我
世界先進都是搞電源管理IC的
好不好
習慣只能呼喚大聲
中美精英還會創新高
有機會啊
是不是 我問你一件事啦
你們會員自己剛剛講
我們賺多少錢啦
好不好 講一下
講一下會員
會員第一天就賺有沒有看到
會員一堆第一天就賺了
第一天就賺了
就會員第一天就賺了
好不好
OK
我相信你五年
10萬點昨天All in 00919
你來亂的
你要相信台灣股市10萬點
你最該做的是買台灣50
或買台積電
有嗎
如果你要買ETF的話
好不好
買ETF的話
當然919也會拉啦
好不好
請問老師
捷積圈口和一般缺口有什麼差別
那個捷積圈口
其實跳了第二個第三個的缺口
第三個第四個的缺口
其實那都是以前
30年來
30年前分析師製造的一個
中文造詣製造一個名詞而已
那沒有任何意義啦
很多沒有任何意義啦好不好
硬要我講我也會講
好不好
硬要掰我也可以掰很多名詞
我再給大家一個故事 你看
Ju Man這個東西有沒有看到
這個我可以看到
它有334萬的點閱率
是
為什麼 因為它很衰
它去歐洲崩潰之旅
我要跟大家講一個東西說
就是你之前也在美國讀書嘛
有時候會不會訂計票失敗
會啊 會齁
美國很常發生
美國很常發生嘛
然後英國 歐洲更懶惰啊
也很多
很多人說歐洲沒有未來啊
因為歐洲人太懶惰了
這我聽很多朋友在講
是
那你那個動不動就被取消班機
取消一堆班機
然後延後後面的行程燒了
損失好幾萬塊
沒錯
那悲哀的人是在抱怨
悲哀的人在抱怨啊
樂觀的人 我拍影片
講我多慘 賣慘啊
334萬的點閱率
他這個334萬的點閱率
可以讓他至少 理論上
至少讓他賺幾十萬
跟甚至幾百萬以上的
這麼多
可以啊 網紅跟藝人一樣
不紅的就是很沒錢
很紅就很有錢
那我之前都沒有拍
都沒有拍啊
你要先從他訂閱人數夠多
你要先累積訂閱人數
至少你訂閱人數要100萬以上
人家訂閱人數也是好幾百萬
是
不好意思
財經界是最好的
沒錯
因為財經界不是每個人做股票
一百萬 唯一一百萬只有我
好 扯遠了
我講的是悲觀的人
哇 好痛苦
樂觀的人
有爆點的我可以賺錢
拍個影片
悲觀的人
哎呀 中美金昨天怎麼會跌
哎呀 微信怎麼要漲不漲
樂觀的人 哎唷 微信要噴出去啦
我就是樂觀的人
你懂不懂
懂不懂
來看一下我多樂觀
微星我直接告訴你
你看一下
7月11號昨天跟你講的喔
昨天跟你講的 3 2 1
創新高我直接告訴你
微星這個
他技術派整理而言
他就是要噴出去的
裡面的周十五大窩投信
他資金籌碼已經整個被鎖起來了
鎖住了
你看台灣股市昨天大跌
欸 昨天
欸 昨天 禮拜五大跌
是禮拜五沒錯吧
禮拜五大跌他是收14k
差點收紅k
昨天三規指數崩盤
是不是
是
他照樣
昨天三規指數崩盤
國際是跌停板的
他照樣留一個非常長的下影線
他整個區間整理平台
完全沒有跌破
我跟你講
微星是來真的
為什麼很多股票都跌不下去
你看我很多股票跌不下去
我的微星是站真的
你告訴我你去找哪個老師
後面給我
直接跟你預告未來
今天我不是只有一檔股票
暫停耶
我不是只有一檔股票
創新高耶
我買什麼賺什麼耶
你現在可以找到誰記一下比我好
你說來聽聽
不是要碰喔
我在講一件事
你們都知道我講的支持的話
你們也知道我不屑去說那些謊話
我100萬粉絲可以作證
這20年來的
我當分析師的生涯
現在我記到最好
國聚那時候不是從200萬做到1200嗎
對不對
對
可是200萬做到1200萬它是漲很快的
我很多會員有些會員是買比較高
你懂我意思嗎
可是現在不是喔
現在是我賺完那個國聚
先賺完年發科再賺完國聚
國聚賺環球金
都製作了一倍喔
對
製作100%
三個100%就快要賺
100萬是賺到快1000萬喔
800到1000萬喔
我之前有跟你講過800到1000萬
因為環球金不只賺100%
環球金不只賺100%
年發科
賺100% 100多%
換國具
國具你可以再換
國具也賺100%
是
再去換
環球金
環球金100%
現在再精彩
環球金還沒出掉
精彩又賺100多%
南亞科去年到今年
200-300%
300%差不多
對股票我翻倍
我所有會員可以見證
我的人生高官
如果在這邊投資的話
我的人生高官最重要是在這邊
最強大的績效
你還不知道我會員
我跟你講
我不知道有什麼東西
有誰可以拿出比我更好的績效
來刺激你
好不好
你趕快來找我吧
趕快找我
你看
而且我最厲害是什麼
你以為最誇張的是
你記不記得我世界天氣
展停版
跌停版的時候
我說我要買
有
我說我最喜歡這種跌停版
就是我家
人家就遲到
Delay 班機延誤
哇 你很悲傷 很難過
人家拍個影片
賺大錢 賺個幾十萬幾百萬
哇 機票錢都賺回來了
真的
你去看那個股票也是一樣
世界先進 跌停版我是不是要用力買
是
而且我用力買怎麼樣
是呀 你沒有夠世界先進的那個啊
我前天跌停都敢擁擠人家嘛
我直接給你秀 我還叫新會員
喔 四小老師也是
算了
四小再麻煩一下
秀出我世界先進
前天的簡訊
我那時候叫新會員買
叫舊會員加碼
跟環球金一樣
環球金那時候賺好幾個展示板
跟時間金
對不對
對
結果後來很多人沒上車
好不容易跌到730
從1000人跌到730
跌25%到30%
是不是
是
環球金我掛跌停板買金
有沒有看到
然後已經買金了不用再買
9點20分
6月8號
6月8號想一想以後
叫你再買一次
除了新位元挂跌停买进以外
已经只有传球金的老会员
也可以试探加码
通通可以请你加码
环球金也好
世界先进也好
为什么我的股票跌停板
我敢加码
你有听到有人国际
跌到一半的时候
加码吗
你有听到一个分析师
讲加码吗
敢讲吗
在之前天天點禮盤敢講加碼嗎
都事後長上去的跟你講我買了
富貴險中求啊各位
富貴險中求我問你一件事情
每個之前都大都股神嘛
我問大家一件事情嘛
這就是我要跟你講我跟別人差別
華興哥今天拉長對不對
昨天有跟你講昨天加碼嗎
那我覺得他有兩把刷子
沒有講昨天加碼 不要
我不要說是被動元件專家
因為我是被動元件專家
好不好
我跟你講那時候我還唱歌
還聽音樂
愛你越久我越被動你知道嗎
那時候一堆網路上的梗
我想什麼都有
小孩你唱一下 你會唱
會
唱一下
愛你越久我越被動
指引你的愛去無頂說
我跟你講2018年的時候
我們就在講這些哏
我跟你講這我都經歷過
你說我是被動原先專家
股票你要有厲害
你要底部的時候講買
是
5347世界先進
你要厲害的就是底部
跌停板就跟你講要買進
環球晶跌停板要跟你講買進
730那邊
在這邊各位
這邊有沒有看到
有
這邊底部你有栽雕啊
環球晶我有沒有說
30%的商務法則
我還知道什麼股票基礎現行來講
是跌35% 跌30%到35%要買進的
什麼股票不行買進
你看我就說國具不適用商務法則
我不是在講嗎
有
都已經腰斬來適用什麼商務法則
所以我教你很多技術派
很多心裡面籌碼面
你不要管台灣股市
現在會不會直接突破5萬點
重點是我股票計較很好
你只要管一件事情
接下來台灣股市
會不會在5年內 4年內30萬點
我會告訴你非常有高的機率
我用台灣50的報酬錄
來跟你講
正常來說
10年內已經算很慢了
慢了
應該說正常情況下
5年內 4年內就會到10萬點
居然會到10萬點
你現在去看那些東西幹嘛
越久你會覺得
講的真的是很對
好不好
去想看你要怎樣分析
我們再看一下
這樣幾分呢
三列了
我們等一下再休息一下
好不好
我要跟你講更多的標果蜜蜜
好不好休息一下而且當然有三大重點休息一下 馬上跟你講投資長您還有哪些股市八卦要分享給投資朋友們好我跟大家講我剛剛不是有三大重點我們還是提一下好了
那我們來看一下
今天有這些八卦都是一樣
來
粉蘭3356點是假的
不會啊
我就說了就基於日派而言
台灣現在真的是不敗的戰神
馬上啦
季線跌破馬上上去
我覺得這個底部基本上
我不敢說會不會馬上突破48000啦
你知道嗎
可是我要告訴你就是說
至少這邊底部42000
底部等於月電越高
42000不會跌破了
是
而且這42000你可能多重底耶
你看這邊42000
這邊42000 你試試看
有沒有
對耶
來我們再把它放大
這邊42000有沒有看到
這邊42000有沒有
這邊有發過號線
有沒有看到這邊
這是42000
這條線是42000
這邊測試一次
測試兩次
測試三次
所以42000是這邊底部 OK嗎
沒有什麼問題
好不好 這是42000 OK嗎
好不好
這是42000
所以我要講的是說
42000中期是一個底部了
短中期是一個底部
所以不要去預設立場
現在你趕快找一些股票
因為很多股票打折了
但有些股票打折
它是可能一絕不振的
我被動研究我覺得就是這樣子
好不好
被動研究就是這樣子
你解值 解值那麼多
不是要準備要賣
我跟你講 如果我沒被騙過就算了
2018年到現在很多人跟我說
那個不是 那個是
你知道我慘動的經驗你知道嗎
那時候網路上
你知不知道
我是不想要講很多事情
那時候只是跟朋友聚會
他說我在爽
他有人硬要給我拍照
不然就不想去的 你懂不懂
我其實講很多事就是這樣子
他說 哇 被動員電跌那麼慘
哲哲 你怎麼還有心情出來
我想說
是啊
所有股票跌我都一定要在家裡
蛤
你知道嗎
沒有啦
以前比較不能接受網路霸凌
我現在比較能接受
我想說管他們的
反正我不是故意害人就好了
以前
那時候還剛網路化你知道嗎
我說我是第一個
第一個做Light 8的
第一個做TG的
然後第一個就是把YouTube的節目
這麼把它做起來做紅的
我什麼都走在前面
所以那時候我不太習慣網路霸凌
現在不是
我現在看不喜歡
我就只要封鎖
沒錯
因為我要告訴你
郭子龍不是網紅
郭子龍是分析師
分析師
我不管你覺得我帥或不帥
每個人現在覺得很多我帥
那是因為我賺錢
我不賺錢我都不帥
所以你喜不喜歡我不重要
我準不準才重要
OK嗎
記得這件事情
好不好
所以喜歡就趕快來找我
應該說覺得我準就來找我
OK嗎
好
是不是
所以有些股票
我不要一直罵變動眼鏡
我只要告訴你
有些股票是真的反彈
有些股票是假的反彈
我分得清楚
你不能
你不能用個台灣股市是真反彈假反彈
我來亂訂這件事情
台灣股市還是今年有機會突破五萬點
我一衝到我就跟你講這件事情
是不是
對
五年內十萬點
居然有機會成十萬點
居然有機會十萬點
你要來找我
好不好
只是有些股票談真你會講
三五三二台勝科
你看也在拉
是不是也暫停
我才是跟我都懶得講
你看
因為我老時候
我只修那個簡訊會員的股票
我要是跟你修一些特別會員的股票
那更多啊
更多展停板
你懂不懂意思
唉
真的對你很不錯
好不好
剛才有人問我資源
資源怎麼看
資源今天還是有展兩三%
沒有怎麼看啊
資源對我來說我覺得也沒什麼跌啊
我覺得也沒什麼跌啦
好不好
你覺得現在跌20%算很嚴重啊
要不要看其他的股票
我們算不錯啦
好不好
然後偽竄我覺得
鴻海為什麼哲哲我沒講
不是鴻海我沒講
因為鴻海第一個
我覺得他可以買
它跌有跌夠深喔 你知道嗎
它跌有跌夠深
就這全值股來講跌有夠深的
跌20幾%
它可以買
但是喔 它可以買
但是它漲不快
就像群聯一樣
群聯可不可以買
可以
但群聯跌的還不夠深
你聽懂嗎
還不夠喔
我覺得不夠
我們看一下1685
到2835
1685除以2835
好問題
不止了喔
那跌很深
對不起 我跟著我說話
謝謝你剛剛有Questure Mark我
結果有質疑我
哇塞
好深耶
很深很深
對不對 2835到1685
對 我群年還有一個原因
我還有一個原因
沒有買的原因
你知道什麼嗎
因為你們很多人
我要跟大家講
如果你今天不要跟別人的股票比
你問單獨群年跟紅海比
我會說群年
你知道什麼嗎
為什麼
因為它有比較有爆發力
可是問題是群年有個執行上的問題
我說錯了
其實最主要我沒有講那麼久的原因是
群聯有個執行上的問題是
它不像中美金一樣
它不像微信一樣
一兩百塊
很多投資朋友
很多 尤其會員
有些人真的很美 很好玩
這也不能怪他們
就沒有要克服心魔
他們看到兩千元就覺得很貴
買個兩百萬
我本來一千萬很多錢
只能買個四五張
然後剩下還要買一堆零股
我說你就買零股就好 就不要
所以為什麼群聯有沒有花那麼多時間
因為價格太高
然後高到你又不像聯發課一樣
你很有名
你很願意買你知道嗎
聯發課你就不覺得它貴了
你懂不懂
會怕
蛤
怕怕的
對 群聯會怕怕
聯發課你就不怕
因為聯發課你們都聽過
所以我覺得群聯在這邊
是真的可以買
好不好
真的可以買
只是我有優先選擇
你看我選擇對了
如果我選擇在低檔買群聯
今天就沒有展廳版了
你懂嗎
可是如果我在低檔的時候
選擇中美金
中美金也沒什麼低檔
我在第一檔的時候選擇
5347世界先進
是不是今天就展停盤
是不是
對
它基本面更明確
為什麼
因為群聯畢竟有展
展了三四倍
不像其他的
南亞科展了十倍
可是你看
世界先進
你說有展嗎
展個一兩倍吧
是不是
因要說有展的話
展個一兩倍而已
一倍多而已
所以世界先進在這邊
是有機會在創新高
因為電源管理的IC
位置的家明明就是暴行
結果你聽成報憂
有人怎麼辦
很多股票真的很強
我再強調一件事
所有會員可以見證
我們的績效
我應該是市場上最猛的
我這兩天只買兩檔股票
所有會員可以見證
我們上萬位的會員
幾千萬上萬位
從前到現在已經有幾萬位了
世界先進
我這幾天大跌的時候買
暫停板
我只買四天進
五四八三中美金
這幾天我只買試驗信跟中美金
今天都展停板
精彩
有夠精彩
我說精彩很強
我還說那時候大戶要拉展停板有沒有
有
是不是
然後2377
微星
我說要噴出去我剛剛可以播重播
微星穿一年多新高
今天我還有兩檔股票穿新高
我一堆股票今天是死貓跳
跌升反彈跌45%才展停
我的微星
我的什麼
我的還有精彩都創新高了
你去哪邊找到這樣的分析
找這樣的股票
想清楚想明白
要結束了 剩幾分鐘
四四 差不多了
想清楚想明白趕快來找我
好不好 我再看一下
我再結論一下
沒有什麼結論的
有啦 再一個結論來
一個新的八卦
最近有沒有看
想不想看奧德賽
想耶
三個小時
來 你看一下
恩隆馬斯克有沒有看到
怎麼樣
他說他的Glock對不對
要製作一個
忠於河馬藝術
就是這個原作的奧德賽電影
為什麼要忠於原作
因為他的黑人
找一個黑人來演
應該說黑人
就是裡面的一個爵士美女
找一個黑人來演
然後他呢
就是最討厭那種DI
反正美國就有這種文化正確
性別正確
反正扯遠他覺得就是
哇 為什麼這諾南演得二的賽不錯
但是呢 明明應該白人演的找黑人來演
他覺得很過分
他覺得很過分 他很討厭第一哀
因為他的長子變成大長女了
性別交換了 變性了
這是事實
來 所以他就很討厭這種第一哀
扯遠了 所以他要報復
報復這些第一哀的電影導演
所以他自己要做一個
荷馬藝術的全場的一個奧德賽電影
那這成本多少
不用多少成本
所以我是說了
以後演員會很辛苦
補習班老師會非常辛苦
你們都不理我
我覺得這件事馬斯克是做得到
那是不是
那我問你一件事
有些電影動輒都幾億的成本
美金都幾百億了
那這些錢省下來做投資就好了
所以你跟我說
AI晶片怎麼會沒人買
隨便都可以
這只是一個演員一個電影
你說沒有人看
我就跟你講
我就舉個例子
我說我媽媽
她有說一堆老人都在看
我上次跟她什麼
什麼真富豪什麼
假什麼
假千金嗎
不是
每次都喜歡看那種
什麼霸氣總裁
真什麼假什麼
小韓 忘記了
反正什麼真貧窮什麼假什麼
之前我給你看過
那時候你就在啦
名字忘記了
忘記了
太多了
小韓一一有沒有印象中
那我那時候給你看一個AI影片
我說我看不出來那是AI
可是我覺得這個應該是AI影片
因為男的太帥 女的太美
連配角都很帥
我說不可能
這個陳北定很重
所以我跟你講那個時候就像AI影片
已經很多人在看AI影片了
所以我跟你講以後真的是會以假亂真
那這些投資是會有意義啊
我講的是其中之一而已啊
老人家很多人在看AI影片啊
他不管你真假他覺得好看就好了
懂不懂
所以你覺得AI投資怎麼會是假的
講那些是假的就是只會看財報
資本支出大於他的收入怎麼辦
入不敷出
廢話嘛你講這是廢話
現在看起來那入不敷出嘛
可是未來怎麼樣
你們要有想像力
他們沒有想像力
說我有想像力
我是跟你講我很激動跟你講
基本上10萬點沒問題
我就是有想像力
所以我不管你
42000還是4萬
還是41000
所以你看我拉回的時候
我現在一堆股票展停板
一堆股票創新高
我一心給我創新高
自己看這線圖
那一堆股票
我只買中美金
最近只買中美金
精采以前就買過
中美金
5347世界現金
為什麼
我買這些AI的一些概念股
因為我看好AI
去想看誰是AI專家
誰是被動眼鏡專家
想清楚 想明白
歡迎來人家去 08066 8085
或叫我來私訊我
不論對我做
哲哲一切一切一切
去想看你要找什麼名字
也益助各位能夠賺大錢
我愛你們
趕快來加入哲哲賺錢的行列
謝謝各位
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家